relationship with religion is evolving
people are I hope becoming more
knowledgeable about the relationship
about the religion itself not just that
I'm born into this religion so this is
who I am but also what that religion is
about and certainly some people are but
there is a great celebration of religion
in India and most people are are very
religious they think of themselves as if
celebrities or anybody else for that
matter wants to do yoga for example I
think that's fine it's a it's a great
system it's very good for you physically
and mentally and one shouldn't make
exaggerated claims for it but one day
I'm gonna have to worry that you know
people take it up and then sometimes
take it into directions which are not
part of the traditional Indian system
for example I think that you know if
people want to wear the bindi the red
dot or on where henna that's cultural I
don't know that that's religion or
philosophy or theology and that's nice
you know it's it's a it's a moment of
recognition when you see it outside of
your own cultural milieu but I think
that yes when people who read one book
and then want to be listened to
respectfully on a religion which is old
which is complex which has many
manifestations then you can feel a
little